go on about how amazing i am real dogs
real raccoons and an extra five million
dollars needed to fix the movie last
minute
that's just the beginning of how wild
putting together the sonic and the
hedgehog films was from improvised
gyrations to next level cruise control
and multiple versions of the hedgehog
himself there is nothing this team
didn't try let's check out green hills
for ourselves i'm just having so much
fun
[Music]
what's that oh just world famous
comedian jim carrey flying into the sky
effortlessly papa's got a brand new
stash
the sonic and the hedgehog team went all
out with these stunts and carrie
well if anyone can soar this smoothly it
would be him
let's just say things got a bit crazy
with sonic on set sorry
some might even say it's a
groundbreaking movie
anyway as they were literally breaking
new ground they made a real mess of the
streets but since all that concrete was
just placed on the road where'd they get
that broken road in the first place
clearly the set and props department how
to work it out for them in this one
yes i had a bonus life
now this
this is a whole new level of driving
james marsden had pretty much the most
chill time looking cool riding with
sonic
lucky for marsden filming this scene was
perfect to get him into character it
feels like a real life video game hit
that accelerator button and we're golden
road trip
don't even think for a second that this
sequel wouldn't come back bigger and
better than the first film we're talking
real helicopters and military machines
on set much unlike a video game this set
was pretty real and the experience for
the actors
well let's just say it's pretty much the
most immersive game there ever was we're
talking sega genesis on a whole new
level
okay but how much do we love this crew
tails and knuckles joining the journey
made for some pretty amazing looking
days on set you could never know when
their full body would be on set or if it
was just going to be their head that was
showing up for filming
some of the more action-oriented shots
require their stunt doubles to take the
reigns anytime we see them collectively
do a spin dash move the crew on set
actually saw these little fuzz balls
sonic is back in all of his forms
whether it was a model doll a bodyless
head or what can we say he's a hedgehog
of many looks it was a blue sandbag that
i would hold when i had to hold sonic
although some of these looks were
definitely better than others
it was a little crudely made a stuffed
animal most of the time it was a tripod
a little piece of tape okay so maybe
sonic didn't have all the most glamorous
moments on set but hey it worked
my favorite scene in the film was having
get to do a fight scene with jim carrey
yeah no kidding that wasn't good which
is pretty cool inside a spaceship this
spaceship totally brought the set to the
next level just look how cool this is
definitely a vehicle up to the doctor's
standards you get in the gizmos and the
gadgets and stuff and fly around in that
ship and they've got that on a crane
thank goodness for the blue screen that
really allowed this ship and crew the
chance to soar it's a real blast i
really liked it really enjoyed it
hey everyone important psa here they
really filmed parts of sonic the
hedgehog in the deserts of abu dhabi
need a casual sandstorm the desert has
you covered
wind turned out to be pretty much the
best natural effects department the crew
could have asked for it's pretty
stunning even without the editing
nothing but the best for this
globe-trotting hedgehog
[Music]
give him a room a slick costume and
absolutely no rules
well this is bound to be good the dance
scene
well
let's just say there was a bit more than
a little bit made up on the spot and
carrie did not hold back there's a lot
of grinding that goes on for sure i'm
very hip centric
i i live in that chakra does he ever
we'd say it's a pretty good chakra even
that t-rex head bite bit was an idea
from the mind of carrie it's brilliant
sir thanks
they did not mess around when it came to
having a big ol hoedown there was some
slick choreography and the perfect
setting
don't tell us you didn't want a groove
in your seat even just a little bit
square dancing and sonic
yeah we'd say that's a pretty winning
combo
so should we get out of here yeah time
to go
sure he might have played the title
character but schwartz did all his
acting completely offset not only did he
lend his voice to the role but his face
as well
well sort of
while he recorded all his lines the
actor's facial movements were being
captured so sonic could embody as much
of the actor's charm as possible oh yeah
this is what it takes for me to turn
into a hedgehog nice job team meow
who's a good boy
well obviously it's this guy
marsden kind of lucked out in terms of
who all his co-stars were he had jim
carrey sonic the hedgehog stand and
dolls and of course
this handsome golden retriever pretty
easy pal to consider your best friend
[Music]
while it looks incredible the mustache
happened to uh
well enhance carrie's experience that
slick piece was unfortunately not
natural and the stylish stash had to be
glued on
with very strong smelling glue and uh
well you get the picture i committed to
the glue you did and i was high the
entire time because of it so showbiz is
tough kid you got you gotta look at the
upside
jeff told me that the script was written
in stone was there improvised dialogue
in this movie though i was not allowed
to create on this movie
all jokes aside yes there absolutely was
so we were able to do a lot of different
versions a lot of different jokes a lot
of different things
with carrie and shorts being part of
this film it's pretty much impossible
not to lean into the improv magic call
optical illusions
tell them i need new frames
jim carrey was always bringing great
lines and coming up with golden nuggets
on the spot but he wasn't alone the
actor's assistant was often on set and
would contribute whenever they came up
with an idea to punch everything up in
fact this hilarious bit of course i want
a latte i love the way you make them not
a carrie original i gotta give uh credit
uh to my assistant nicole for that line
nice one nicole
the raccoons are back hey who let these
wild animals on set
well turns out it was the producers
these raccoons had been well prepared
for their big moment in the trash cans
we're talking full raccoon racing
choreography get out of there come on oh
come on get out of there food lured the
animals to the garbage cans and as for
getting through those doggy doors well
buzzers and food were the key these
furry ones might have a bright future
with this kind of skill
getting the chance to work with jim
carrey is a dream for loads of actors
and james marsden was no exception
one of the actors that i looked up to
the most
growing up in this in this business the
two got to really bond and had what
looked like super chill vibes on set
nope
wrong major i'm in charge okay well
kerry might not always have been so
perky but hey comes with the job
how many sonics were there on set
exactly while schwartz was never really
on the set there were plenty of sonics
around keeping everything in order there
were three full sculptures of sonic
detailed to various degrees and of
course the solo head and if you really
wanted to get abstract there was also a
tennis ball stand-in too oh yeah and a
post-it note at one point so with all
the options how will you be taking your
hedgehog today so many sonic forms to
choose from
[Music]
he's done a whole lot of incredible
roles but this one was special for
carrie since the team invited him to do
what he does best
it really became a total playground and
a chance to show off his best authentic
and spontaneous self we can totally
understand why he considers this one of
his new favorite roles
oops it uh seems they went a bit over
budget with this one after the awkward
first design of uh
remember this strange looking sonic
redesigning the whole shebang cost 5
million and hit the company so hard that
they wound up closing their studio in
vancouver he's gonna be okay right
i'm a vet tom i don't even know what i'm
looking at here both sonic and the
hedgehog movies bring such a cool blast
of nostalgia and some solid cinema for
the people who didn't grow up playing
these games on their segas is it too
early to start asking about a third
movie we'll just be over here dusting
off our old video games until then
you